NETO MARIN: Hi, I'm Neto.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Hi, I'm Jessica.
NETO MARIN: And we are
both from the Actions
on Google Developer
Relations team.
And we are here today to
introduce you a new series.
We are very excited
about this series.
It's Behind the Actions, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yay.
NETO MARIN: So what is
this about, Jessica?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
the Behind the Actions
is all about deep dives
into building for Actions
on Google and Google Assistant.
And so today, we're
actually going
to be starting with the basics.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And we're going
to be building our first action.
NETO MARIN: Cool.
Cool.
So we've got to go through
[INAUDIBLE] understanding
where they should start, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: And until we are
actually testing a real device?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, on a
Home, which will be super fun.
NETO MARIN: Oh, nice.
Yeah, this is very good.
This is cool.
And like I said, this is a
new series we are starting.
If you have any
comments, feedback
please let the comments below.
And also, follow us on Twitter.
We have the Actions
on Google handle.
In general, we post about
new blog posts, events
that we are going,
announcements.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Other videos like these.
NETO MARIN: Other
videos like this.
So we are waiting
for your feedback.
And let's start building.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So what
are we building, first of all?
NETO MARIN: The idea today
is more, for example, build--
in this case, going to build
the Lucky Number Calculator
[INAUDIBLE] think about.
You can tell me
your favorite color.
And based on that, we
complete your number.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So the action
is going to, I'm
assuming, greet me.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And ask
me what my favorite color is?
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And then
me, as a user, I tell you,
my favorite color's purple.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
And then based on
this color, we're
going to make some
AI machine learning--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh.
NETO MARIN: No, no.
I'm kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
It's just counting the
number of letters in the word
and then calculate something.
But before we jump
into this cold,
there are some three
elements we must
understand when you are
developing for the Google
systems.
I think the first one would be
the Google Assistant itself.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: And we can
say that the platform--
like, for example, it's where
your action going to live.
So when you try to talk
with your Google Assistant,
your action will be downloaded.
And then you'll be
able to interact
with the Google
Assistant, the device
Assistant built in.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
You don't even have
to download it.
It's already available once
it's out in production.
And so Google
Assistant's all about
that conversation users can
have with Google, right?
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And so you're
going to be able to talk
to it and be able to invoke
our action that we're building.
NETO MARIN: Our
actions, exactly.
And there's several devices that
have Google built in, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: So I remember
some very cool headphones,
the new headphones you can wear.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Those are so cool.
NETO MARIN: You also
have TV is already
working on Google
systems, so we don't
need to memorize the
number of the channel.
So just say, hey, turn
on the sports and say,
you can watch this--
something like that.
But also have some other
formats, right, Jessica?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, laptops.
NETO MARIN: Home, of course.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Home Mini.
NETO MARIN: And we'll have the
[INAUDIBLE] recently announced.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh, those are gorgeous.
NETO MARIN: They are great.
Yeah.
I have in the kitchen.
I like to play
with my kids that,
because they can
say some stories
and they can watch there.
It's very cool.
To make calls, for example.
So it's very nice, very nice.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Definitely.
Definitely.
NETO MARIN: And
then as a developer,
we can use this platform
and extend this platform
to our own apps.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And in this world,
apps-- we call them actions.
And so we're going to be
using the term actions.
And that-- it's similar to
an app on any other platform.
I know you have an
Android background,
so I really love this analogy.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
I used to talk about this
when I'm on presentations.
It's because if you think--
sometimes it's hard to not
say the abstraction, something
like that.
But if you take
the Android world--
so we have the
Android as a platform
is like the Google Assistant.
So we have all the other
applications there.
Then, if I have the
each device that runs
an Android-- can be your
phone, your tablet, your car,
for example, running
Android auto.
But also, you have the apps
that each developer develops
to deliver to their users.
That's our actions.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: So I like
to think on that way
to imagine we are building
apps for the whole system
that we call actions for
the Google Assistant.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I love analogy.
That's so great,
because it really
does identify how they're
kind of equivalent.
But the biggest
difference is that you
don't have to download--
NETO MARIN: No.
You just--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: --actions.
NETO MARIN: --ask for it.
You start talking,
and the action
will be totally right
available right now.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
That's so cool.
NETO MARIN: So you just
talk with your Assistant.
So this is one thing I really
like about Google Assistant,
that it don't need to
install or go and search.
And just ask.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
And so what it
sounds like is, what
we're going to be
doing is, we're
going to be making a project
on Actions on Google--
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
--which is the platform
for Google Assistant.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Cool.
NETO MARIN: So where
should I start?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So we should start
with the console, which is the
console.actions.google.com.
Start there and build
a project there.
NETO MARIN: And I think it's
pretty straightforward, right?
Just remember, console, actions.
It's great.
And it will be your
home from now on.
If you're becoming an
Action developer-- #AoGDevs,
our hashtag on
Twitter, by the way--
you can just log into
the Actions console
and start the project.
Jessica, you show us?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Jessica-- she
has a video on the channel.
So if you want to know
more about the console,
she recorded a gorgeous
video about how to--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Thanks.
NETO MARIN: --use the console.
Then you can see much more
details on that video.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Definitely.
So we're going to
start off here.
Right now, we have no projects.
And so what we'll do is,
we'll add a project here.
And let's call this
project Lucky Calculator?
NETO MARIN: Great.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right?
NETO MARIN: Sounds good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And when
it comes to-- "calculator."
Haha.
And I'm going to
click Create Project.
And this is just a project ID.
This is not actually the
name of the action, right?
NETO MARIN: No.
Good point.
Yes.
Because it's not the way that
we interact with your actions.
So you don't need to start
over think right now,
oh, how's the name?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I know.
Having to name something
immediately is hard.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
And even the
domain's unavailable.
I'm kidding.
Now we have this screen.
So we have a bunch
of categories here.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: So
it's kind of, what
can I do from a bunch
of these things?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh my gosh, yeah.
So this is where you
could just use a category
to label your action.
But seeing that we're making a
custom action that's not really
going to--
it doesn't fit into one of
these categories neatly.
We're actually going to make
it using the conversation.
NETO MARIN: OK.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
we'll click on that.
And that will take us
into the actual home page
of the console, which is great.
NETO MARIN: And
here is the set up.
So the Quick Setup
that says, decide
how your action is evoked.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
let's click on that.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
What Jessica was
talking about-- don't
need to [INAUDIBLE] by
before the name of the ID
project, something like that.
And here is the screen
where we actually
add the name, how our
action be invoked.
So, for example, we
can use this when
you say, hey, Google, ask to--
and then we must say
the name of the action.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: But to
choose these names,
we have some policies, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Definitely.
Yeah, you can't have action
names there are only one word.
They need to be multi-word.
They can't be of a brand
that you don't own.
And they can't be Google.
So you can't build an
action called Google.
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: Yeah, yeah.
And, of course,
potentially some--
sometimes we come with some
cool names, start up services,
don't know.
But, unfortunately, if
you try to say that name,
it's actually pretty
hard for the Assistant
to develop natural
language processing
and understand
what you're saying.
So before you test, before
you actually decide the name,
try to hear how the Assistant is
expecting to hear from you when
you invoke the action.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Even how
your users are going to say it.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Because
sometimes, some words
could be real tongue twisters--
just like that sentence.
Blah, blah, blah.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
And remember, there's a lot of
non-native English speakers.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: And maybe
some challenge words
should be avoided, I think.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
So for this action, I'm thinking
we should call it "lucky number
calculator"?
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Sounds good.
Lucky number calculator.
And then we can hear, also,
how they expecting, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Yeah.
So let's click here.
SPEAKER 1: Lucky
number calculator.
NETO MARIN: OK, sounds good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
That sounds good, yeah.
NETO MARIN: Then,
remember to save.
Always save, please.
And now, this saving our agent.
And it's good.
We are good to go.
Now, this is what define
the base for our action.
So we have the
name of our action.
Now we need to start
creating our action.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, totally.
We need the functionality of it.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So when it comes
to what happens under the
hood, the user is going to say,
hey, Google, talk to
lucky number calculator.
The device picks it up, sends
it to a Google Assistant.
It figures out, it's
going to hit our code.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And
then, after that, we
have to give it a response.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And then once the user
gives us something back, we have
to figure out what they want.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And
that would be really hard,
because imagine someone
saying, I love purple,
or, my favorite color is pink.
There's so many different
ways of saying that.
How do you process that
without going crazy?
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: We have
a very nice tool.
Call it Dialogflow.
That will be very tight
integrated with all the actions
on Google Console.
So from here, we'll be able, for
example, to start our action,
creating our first action--
[INAUDIBLE] an action.
And it will add us to
the Dialogflow console.
And when we hit
there, we're going
to explain more about the
difference between the two
consoles and how we're
going to work [INAUDIBLE]..
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So I'm
going to click on Actions.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And that takes us here.
And then--
NETO MARIN: Oh, actually, yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
And so this is all the
functionality we want.
So I'm going to click on Adding.
NETO MARIN: What is this?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right?
And so this is where
we have this define.
What is the type of intent
or type of functionality
we're going to provide?
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Imagine intents like intention.
So the user has the
intention to do something,
to ask something to our action.
And this is what we
are talking about.
We have some pre--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: There
are some cool ones in here.
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
What does it mean?
Because, for example, instead
of having to train your agent
to detect all the possible
ways to say, for example,
get fortune, something
like that, we already
have this pre-trained,
this kind of an action.
So what we call building tents.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
And it lets Google know that
that particular intent is
all about giving a fortune.
So when it has to figure
out which action to surface,
it knows.
You already found
something there.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
But in our case, we are
building a custom one.
So let's go with Custom
Intent and hit Build.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So let's click Build.
And it looks like
it opened a new tab.
NETO MARIN: Yes, one more tab.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And now
I'm in a different world.
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: And this
is Dialogflow, people.
This is where, now, our natural
language processing stuff
will be much easier.
Imagine if you have to
implement this by yourself,
like having to handle all
the languages, for example.
We handle more
than 20 languages.
So imagine you have to
handle all the languages,
do all the processing on
the words and the phrases,
and then identify what the
user means by that method.
Yeah, crazy, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Too much.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Dialogflow is a very cool tool.
It's free.
It's open to use for
all of the projects
so you can plug and use
right away in your projects.
So it's very nice.
And you're going to see here,
we will type a few expressions,
we going to some answers,
and it will be great.
Let's see.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, definitely.
So it looks like
Dialogflow gives us,
for free, two intents already.
So one's called the
Fallback intent.
And the other one is
the Welcome intent.
NETO MARIN: Cool.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And so let's actually
go and explore a little bit
of the Welcome intent first.
So in here-- I'm going
to click right in here.
And that'll take us
into the intent page.
And we have a couple
of things going on.
We're going to
skip over context,
because that's not being used.
An event-- right
here, it says welcome.
So anytime that this agent
in Dialogflow is invoked,
that triggers this event.
For Actions on Google,
we don't really
have to worry about
that component just yet,
because that's when
it first greets it.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
And just to make clear,
why this is here,
see if Action on
Google that we're
using, because you
can use Dialogflow
to build agents for several
different platforms.
So it can go with many, many,
many options, social networks,
shared applications.
So we can check--
when we start integrating
with the Google Assistant,
you'll see other links there.
Then, you could use the
same agent, the same code
to integrate with your other
platforms, if you want.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Super cool.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And so this one
has already some
training phrases
that they give us for free.
And so When.
It comes to training
phrases, this
is what we would be adding to
give to Dialogflow to train,
to match whatever the user
says to match with this intent.
And so this is some
training phrases,
like hello, hi, howdy, hi there.
NETO MARIN: Ways you
start the conversation.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: That
makes a lot of sense.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
we're going to scroll down.
And so down here--
NETO MARIN: Responses.
What is this?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So it looks like this
is what our action's
going to give back to the user.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
Nice.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So here, let's change
this to make it customized.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, it's
because when someone asks,
talk to the lucky
number calculator,
we are expecting to,
for example, receive
some instruction, right?
OK, what should I do next?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, exactly.
NETO MARIN: So we can start
saying what the user can do.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So I think we
should keep the hi.
NETO MARIN: That's good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So, hi.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, have
a polite action here.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: "Hi,
what is your favorite color"?
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Sounds good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
what's really nice is,
if we keep it as
multiple, then Dialogflow
will be able to randomly
choose one from this.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
Nice.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So I'm going
to just copy-paste this part.
NETO MARIN: Control-C.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Thank you.
NETO MARIN: It's not a Mac.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So I'm
going to replace all of these.
That way--
NETO MARIN: Nice.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: --we have
just that variety of greeting.
So then it doesn't feel robotic.
Because imagine every
time you see me,
I'm always like, hello, Neto.
[LAUGHTER]
And next time, hello, Neto.
That would be weird.
NETO MARIN: You know,
some people do this.
It's creepy, but OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe they are robots.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Maybe.
Well, but the brain is very
mechanical in that sense.
If it works, then go for it.
We want to have something
that's a little more
loose of an action.
NETO MARIN: OK, yes.
I like it.
Remember to save again.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And then we save.
Perfect.
NETO MARIN: Now,
we can test this?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: On the device.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: You
want to test on the device?
You want to test this
in the simulator first?
NETO MARIN: Let's
go to simulator.
Good idea.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right?
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: That's for
the simulator [INAUDIBLE]..
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah,
because I would love to show--
NETO MARIN: Calm down.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: --from here,
how do we go to the simulator
and be able to show
that connection?
So we're going to go on
the left-hand side and hit
Integration.
And under Integration,
there will be the page
that Neto was mentioning of
all the different integrations.
But the best one is
Google Assistant.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So we're
going to click on that.
We're going to scroll down.
And then we're going to enable
the auto-preview changes.
That way, if there's any
changes on her Dialogflow,
it automatically gets populated
on your Actions on Google.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And click Test.
NETO MARIN: Oh.
What's happening?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: That's
because I didn't click it.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
It's opened another tab.
Oh, my god.
No, it's because now we
are going to the simulator.
So this is very cool.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: The
simulator of Actions on Google.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, yeah.
Good point.
If you want, for
example-- if you
are building for
other platforms,
you want to test
integration, Dialogflow
also as a tool for you to test,
say, things to the Dialogflow.
But here is specifically
about the Actions on Google,
the Google Assistant.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
NETO MARIN: But there's some
nice things, some cool stuff
on this screen, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh my gosh, yes.
The simulator is,
I think, the best
tool to be able to test
out your action just
to see if what you're
coding, what you're building
is really happening.
NETO MARIN: Mm-hmm.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And so in
here, we're in the simulator.
On this main page, it's going to
be the log of the conversation.
And on the right will be
what is displayed to the user
if it has some visual
elements to it.
NETO MARIN: And we can, for
example, see here on Surface?
We can change the surface to see
how your action is performing
on a phone or a speaker
or a screen-enabled device
like smart displays.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: It also
can change language
if you are trying
multi-language.
Yes.
Spanish or Brazilian Portuguese.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: All of them.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
So we have a lot of them.
And even if you are
trying, for example,
some service that
you need location,
you could walk or
change the location.
Right now, you're
Googleplex, where you are.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, we're here.
NETO MARIN: But you could change
this location if you want.
And then you have
a bunch of tabs.
We won't go through
all this right now.
I think it's not
necessary in this video.
We are already learning
a lot of things today.
But you can explore this
later and see, for example,
how the request is going
and how the response is
coming from the Assistant.
You can see all the
JSON communication,
because all the communication
between the Assistant
and Dialogflow, it's
all based on JSON.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: So you could
see what's going on
and if you have any errors.
We have errors and debug.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, yeah.
That's something I really enjoy.
Whenever there is an
error, it automatically
takes you to that tab and
it tells you the error name.
And that's usually when I'm
like, hello there, old friend.
I see you again.
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: It's good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
can we test this one out?
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Let's see if this works.
NETO MARIN: You can
type or talk or click.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I'm a clicker,
so I'm going to click on it.
SPEAKER 1: All right,
getting the test version
of Lucky Number Calculator.
SPEAKER 2: Greetings.
What is your favorite color?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Nice.
NETO MARIN: Wow,
deploying, it's working.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
The demo writes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Well,
what's going on here
is, how you saw, it's going to
the Assistant, asking for, hey,
do you have some action called
Lucky Number Calculator?
And the Assistant say,
yeah, actually, I have.
And this testing
is in your account.
Because I don't know
if you realized,
but we called it here.
And Jessica didn't did any kind
of deploy or something like--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
Didn't have to.
NETO MARIN: --send it to that.
When you do the testing,
it's already enable
any or all devices.
So if you have
anything configured
to the Google Assistant,
you're already working there.
So even you have a same team
sharing the same account
or different accounts, it
would very fast, very quickly
enabled to the other
people to test.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
It's accessible,
which is really nice.
And there's also other ways
that you could do that.
And we'll talk about that
when it comes to releasing
and how do you actually
test in a larger scale, too.
NETO MARIN: So let's--
excuse me.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sure.
So we're in that
transition phase
where our action has given
a question to the user.
We said hi.
It gave you a question.
And now we have to allow
the user to respond back
with their favorite color.
And then we have to
build the functionality
to capture that and then
do our machine learning
really great, fun stuff.
NETO MARIN:
[INAUDIBLE],, yeah, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
All his analysis.
And then return back a response.
NETO MARIN: You're going to see,
it's, like, 100 lines of code.
Prepare yourself.
[LAUGHTER]
Brace yourselves.
I'm kidding.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So we have to build
that turn of conversation.
User says their favorite
color, and we're responding
with the lucky number.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
So we are here.
I just clicked on Cancel
to stop the emulator.
I go back to the other tab,
where we have the Dialogflow.
I can close the test.
And then I'll go
back to intents.
So again, you see,
again, the full welcome.
We can now create a new intent.
So this new intent is what
we are building, exactly.
So in this case, it's our
lucky number calculator.
So let's call it that
Lucky Number is good?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sure.
NETO MARIN: Just Lucky
Number, because then we
will return the lucky number.
Context-- we are
not talking this.
It's a much more deeper topic.
In the future, we will have,
for sure, an episode about this.
Just have in mind, it is a
way you can remember what's
going on the conversation.
So like a person, you can--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Keep the context.
NETO MARIN: --keep your context.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: So the same thing.
Events, already talked about.
So let's add the
training phrases.
And this point,
remember, the action
already greeted
the user, saying,
what's their favorite color?
So now, how would you
answer this question?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I think I would
answer by saying something like,
my favorite color is purple.
NETO MARIN: My favorite
color is purple.
Right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: Is right?
Is good?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, yeah.
NETO MARIN: So what happened?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh.
NETO MARIN: There's
something here.
Yellow you see here highlighted.
What happened here is, our
natural language processing
tool-- that's
Dialogflow-- identified
that purple is a color and then
is mapping this as an entity.
Because it's something on
the real world that probably,
based on this phrase, is
something that the user
once you communicate
your action.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
Dialogflow is
smart enough and is
aware of things
like colors, time--
not just time of the
day, but then also time
in regards to days.
NETO MARIN: CDs, countries.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So many things.
NETO MARIN: Currencies.
There's a lot.
In our documentation page, you
have a specific-- on Dialogflow
documentation, sorry.
There's a specific page
with all the system.
We call system
entities, this case.
You could create your own.
For example, if you
have a unicorn color,
you have something like that--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I do.
That sounds great.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Yeah, my daughter
will love this color.
[LAUGHTER]
Then I can go to Entities, here,
and create a new entity custom
color or [INAUDIBLE] color
or something like that.
You can and your colors to that.
But in this case, let's work
only the well-known colors.
Let's say that.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So we should provide just
more than one training phrase,
because I don't think
a machine learning
model is happy with one.
NETO MARIN: I think not enough.
[INAUDIBLE],, for example,
you said, my favorite color
is purple.
But since they asked,
what's your favorite color?
I would say just,
orange, for example.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh,
yeah, just respond back.
See, and this is what I like.
There's so many
different varieties
that you could just provide
Dialogflow a handful
and it figures out the rest of
the diversity of that phrase.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
This is the point.
If you have, for example--
imagine you are building
a service for your custom
service.
Let's say that.
And you have a bunch of ways
that people make question
to your call center.
And you have these
questions already
collected on a spreadsheet,
something like that.
You can also import these
from the spreadsheet,
from other sources, and
put here as a training.
But take care.
Don't put, also,
too much questions.
Because then what
could happen is,
all the process get confused
by the amount of question.
You are overloading this.
And then gets confused
with another questions
from another [INAUDIBLE].
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh, another intent.
Exactly.
NETO MARIN: So you
need to be very
clear on delimiting the limit
between one intent and another.
But in our case, I think
orange one, or say,
"my favorite color is purple."
"Orange."
"I like blue."
What else?
"Is green."
Something like that.
So I think we have a
good variety, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, totally.
Especially for this demo,
I think we're good here.
I believe we recommend doing
about 10 to 15 training phrases
for a production-level action.
NETO MARIN: So right now, we
have a very straightforward
training phrases.
But now, I can respond to
the user about something.
I want to make sure that it's
understanding my question--
not question, sorry.
My answer.
I can go here, Add
Response, for example,
and I can create just
a dummy answer just
to make sure that
this is working.
And then I say, yeah,
let's imagine that we
have here a polite action.
Say, yes, or, nice.
"I like--" I want to
refer to the same color.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: The
color that the user said.
NETO MARIN: How could I do this?
If you go here, you see
when you click on this part,
there is a parameter name.
So this color that the user
said is mapped to a parameter.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
And so we could use that
variable or that parameter
in this response, now.
NETO MARIN: So I
would say here, color.
Why color?
So it's like this action is
responding, "like I nice"
and the color for
whatever you say to it.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So this is
not your machine learning part,
right?
NETO MARIN: No, no.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: This
is not your fancy math.
This is just for testing.
NETO MARIN: Just
for test, exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Perfect.
NETO MARIN: You got it.
[LAUGHTER]
It's just like, let's warm up.
So Save.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Always.
NETO MARIN: Remember
to save lucky number.
And again, integration.
And then-- example, we can
go just without hitting this,
but there is sometimes some
delay between the propagation
of the new version.
So for faster here, let's just
export the lucky number intent
here and then test again.
You'll see another
simulator going up.
And then we can close
the previous one.
No problem.
And then let's try again.
But this time, I'm going to
answer it when the action ask
me about my favorite color.
So going to use the same again.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
Getting the test version
of Lucky Number Calculator.
SPEAKER 2: Hi.
What is your favorite color?
NETO MARIN: I'm
going to say I like--
let's use a color
that's not on my list.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Pink.
NETO MARIN: Pink.
It's [INAUDIBLE] of fashion.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Nice I like pink.
NETO MARIN: That's it.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Nice.
So we confirmed--
NETO MARIN: It's so intelligent.
I like it so much.
No, I'm kidding.
So what we're going
to have here--
can hit Cancel.
So just end the session.
But it's not so useful, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: No, no.
We want something dynamic.
But we at least know that our
intent that we filled out works
and that the training
phrases was triggered
using a different word--
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
--which is great.
So now what we want to
do is grab that color
and, in our back end--
NETO MARIN: Oh, back end, no.
Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Do all the fun stuff
that you promised me.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
I had to show my
[INAUDIBLE] machine learning
and everything else.
So again, close this case
and go back to your intent.
Click again on, in our
case, Lucky Number.
And you'll see, here, all the
things we already entered.
At the end of the
page, and scroll down,
you'll see fulfillment.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
What is fulfillment?
NETO MARIN:
Fulfillment's the way
that we actually going
to link the Dialogflow
to our culture, the web hook.
Because this is the
way that we offer
to connect to your back end,
to the Google and Dialogflow
server.
Because how we could know how to
send your request instead of--
for example, we don't
like you to keep
pulling to ask for something.
Then the easiest way, just
call a web hook-- like URL
that you're going to give to us.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: But in this case--
so enable fulfillment here.
And then we can enable web
hook call for this intent.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So our welcome line, we are not
going to touch our back end.
NETO MARIN: No.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Because it's not needed.
It's overhead we don't need.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
that one we'll leave as is.
This one, when this gets hit,
that goes and hits our code.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
We need these action
goes to the back end.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Nice.
NETO MARIN: There's another
option here without enabling.
Right now, it's about
this [INAUDIBLE]..
So you could enable
these two if you
need to check some
parameters, other thing.
But it's not default
because right now--
so remember to save.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Always save.
[LAUGHTER]
Always save.
NETO MARIN: And then, done.
Look.
There's some--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm.
Something different.
NETO MARIN: What is this?
The screen has got this
green thing going on.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
It looks like that the agent
is actually being trained.
So it's grabbing all
the training phrases
and creating the--
NETO MARIN: Training phrases?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes, it's
grabbing the training phrases
to make the model for
the machine learning.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And so it looks
like it just created all that.
And then it finished.
NETO MARIN: Because
it's not just not
doing, if this
equal your phrase--
it's actually
creating more options.
So this is what
it's saying to us.
You'll see a bunch of these
communication going out,
sometimes, on here.
And there is another option
here, on the left menu.
Fulfillment.
So click here.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So this is a fulfillment in
the regards of connecting
our actual code to Dialogflow.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right?
OK.
NETO MARIN: One
of the option here
is to use external web hooks.
So imagine where we have your
own backhand configurator
can use this.
You can enter your URL here.
Only requirement, that
it must be HTTPS--
a secure point.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Got to be safe.
NETO MARIN: But
there's no dangerous
should put my basic
authentication
here, user name, password.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: No, you
could totally do that, yeah.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, because
this is SSL communication.
And this information will
be stored in our servers.
Nobody has access.
If you need something else,
like API key or something,
it could go here.
Enter a key in [INAUDIBLE].
So imagine, API key
or a specific header
that you want to use
it can also use here.
So no problem.
You can use your own server.
But we don't have a server.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Well, we
don't need a server for this.
NETO MARIN: We
don't need, exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, exactly.
We could use something that
Dialogflow already has built
in, which is the inline editor.
NETO MARIN: This is great.
So here, I have my code
right on this screen.
I don't need to go and create,
download an intstant key,
create nothing, and
just type my code here.
And just an explanation--
I kind of lazy, people.
So I'm going to replace all this
code with one magic comment.
But the point is--
I've got to explain why.
You see here,
Dialogflow fulfillment.
But we're going to
change this, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
We're going to use our Actions
on Google client library
instead.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
This client library has
been built by our team.
And we take care.
It's open source.
And it's on GitHub.
You can take a look, can open
issues if you find something,
or can talk with us if
you have any problem.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Well,
don't talk to us through that.
Talk to us through Twitter.
But, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: Ah, of course.
But then, if you have any
problem with the library,
It's good, because
then this will help
you wrapping all functionality.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh my gosh,
it makes it so much easier.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Like, you don't need to take
care about the JSON format,
specifically.
So you can go use the library.
You're going to see, here.
It's very useful.
But if you're not a Node.js
person, you can also use Java.
So we have recently
announced the Java client
library and Java [INAUDIBLE].
So you can use on Java
[INAUDIBLE] environments.
And we are planning to pull
out more tools and libraries.
So stay tuned.
But so I'm going to
replace this code.
I'm kind of lazy, you know.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: The
power of the internet.
NETO MARIN: No.
[LAUGHTER]
Jessica--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: That was me.
NETO MARIN: It was.
But no problem.
We have here.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: There we go.
NETO MARIN: Let's do the magic.
Yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yep.
Woohoo, it's there.
NETO MARIN: What we
have here is basically,
we are importing some
things we might use.
For example, the library
has this Dialogflow,
the basic objects.
So it's where all the
functionalities, the features
are.
But also, we have base
card on the image.
These are other
classes, other objects
that we might use to have a
rich response, for example.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: But we have, also--
promising one more
episode, we have something
about this in the future.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: We will.
NETO MARIN: Right now, let's
use only the Dialogflow here,
because we don't
need the other one.
And then these others,
just about the function.
So it's required
by this, because we
are hosting this on a Firebase
Cloud Functions, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Exactly, yeah.
So under the hood,
what's happening
when we do hit
Deploy is, it's going
to spin up a Firebase
Functions only project.
It's going to
create the project.
It's going to upload our code.
It's going to deploy it.
And then it's going to
connect the URL to Dialogflow
and do all this magic.
So we need to have
that, because that's
how we use Firebase Functions.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Then, here, we are
starting the Dialogflow app
that we imported here before.
Then, here is the intent.
So remember when we create the
intent, lucky number, there?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yep.
NETO MARIN: Here
is where I mapped
that intent, that it's
on the Dialogflow side
to in the web hook
on my back end
to say, hey, when the user says
something this intent, this
is the code that will
answer your request.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So when the user says
a color, Dialogflow
does the machine learning,
matches it with the intent.
That intent name is that name.
NETO MARIN: Be the same, yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So those match.
NETO MARIN: And here you
can see the parameter.
So remember, when you check the
parameter there with the color,
use the same name here.
So, color.
And then here is my
extremely advanced code.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh.
Hm.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
So we got [INAUDIBLE] of
that color and multiply--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: By 35.
NETO MARIN: 35?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Is
35 a special number?
NETO MARIN: No,
I can't say that.
This is my machine
learning thing, here.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Top secret?
NETO MARIN: Top secret, yes.
I run after a million
of lines of code,
and then I came
with this number.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh,
so that's the answer.
So then we grab
the lucky number.
We do your really
cool mathematics.
NETO MARIN: And what is this?
I'm returning the
conversation.ask.
So you have your lucky number.
This is when we calculate it.
Imagine you have
here your API call.
You can read from database
or whatever you want.
And then you have
conv.ask or conv.close.
What is the difference?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So conv.ask is
where you could give the
response a string where
the conversation
continues with the user.
When you use conv.close
and you still
pass in the string,
what happens is,
the conversation
ends after that.
So there's no more
dialogue after that.
NETO MARIN: Exactly
in this case,
we could use close to
finish the conversation.
I think, let's change for close.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I
think that makes sense.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, because
you asked the number.
I said the color, asked
the number, return.
I think it's done.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: We don't need.
And then we're going to hit--
and this last line,
just remember, must--
it will be there when you
started doing your code.
Can, like I said,
replace at the top code.
But this last line--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh, you need.
NETO MARIN: --must
be this way because
this
DialogflowFirebaseFulfillment
is the name of the function
that Dialogflow is expecting
to hit in your back end.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: So don't
change this name, please.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Let's just delete that
"Want to try again,"
because we're ending
the conversation.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Since we changed that,
let's make it so
that it really ends.
NETO MARIN: OK.
Finish here.
So is lucky number.
And then I can hit Deploy
right now and send [INAUDIBLE]..
Successfully provision it.
So it means it already
sent to the call function.
So create your project.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Project.
NETO MARIN: But
remember, right now, it's
speeding up the deploy.
It's creating your instance,
downloading your dependencies.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
All the requirements.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
So in the first time,
it's not so fast.
It would take one minute,
maybe, or a few seconds.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: But then,
the following executions
would be much faster.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, totally,
because you're not having to do
all of that structural inte--
the structure to
just start it up.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So after that,
it's just those minor changes.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
And let's remember,
we don't have
version control inside here.
So if you change
your code, you're
not sure about what
you're changed,
save these on another
editor, something like that.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: And do your
own version control.
Because here, when
you change, it's
updated in the Cloud
Functions projects.
So if you change something you
don't remember how you did,
you're lost.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
Oh, no, no.
Totally.
Yeah, you always want
to use version control
whenever you're developing.
Because I know
you don't discover
that you need to do that
until it bites you in the tush
and you're just like,
why didn't I do that?
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: Yes, exactly.
In this case, we're going to
test on the device right now.
I think we can mute so--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, yeah.
I'll totally mute it.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
GOOGLE HOME: The mic's back on.
NETO MARIN: You see?
Now we can talk with her.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
But we do need to wait
for it to deploy completely.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, sure.
We are waiting.
[LAUGHTER]
And, by the way,
in this episode,
we're going to stop
right after this--
how can I say?
This goal, that it's
create the action and test.
And in the next
episode, you're going
to see how we can take this
action that we just developed
and publish for everybody use.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exciting.
NETO MARIN: So we have to
wait a little bit more.
So it's deployed.
Yeah!
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah!
NETO MARIN: Deploy dance.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: It worked.
NETO MARIN: Now we can use?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: So I'll go
to Integration again,
just make sure that
it's integrated.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, let's
just test this out just in--
NETO MARIN: Remember, this
name here, Lucky Number,
must match the intent name here.
So Lucky Number here is OK.
Go again Integration,
Google Assistant.
It's there, Lucky Number.
Test.
But this time, we won't
use the simulator.
Right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
We don't have
to, because we have
something else.
NETO MARIN: Oh, nice.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I'm so nervous.
NETO MARIN: Me, too.
The chance--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I know.
NETO MARIN: --to go
wrong is big, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: OK.
OK, Google, talk to
lucky number calculator.
GOOGLE HOME: Sure.
Here's the test version of
Lucky Number Calculator.
SPEAKER 2: Greetings.
What is your favorite color?
NETO MARIN: My favorite
color is brown.
GOOGLE HOME: Your
lucky number is 175.
NETO MARIN: Whoa, yes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah!
Woohoo.
[LAUGHTER]
NETO MARIN: We are winner.
We are the champ-- no.
So you see how its easy?
I didn't upload nothing.
I didn't connect
any cable to there.
Just the power
source is connected.
So that's great.
So it's ready to test.
And you can test your--
this something I really
like about mobile device
when I was developing
for Android,
and now that I
develop for this--
it's because you can see your
code running and actually
working right beside you.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
It's a real thing.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
It's very nice.
[LAUGHTER]
But so I think, for this
one, I think we are good.
So these are the way you can
wrap up on doing your action.
With these, you are able
to make more changes.
For example, can go back
to Dialogflow and then
you can create more intents--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: --more entities,
if you need, and keep testing.
So I think it is, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: So in
the next episode,
you're going to see how
to publish this action
and make it available
for everybody.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Everyone.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
So you can share with your
mom, with your partner,
with everybody.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: So it can test.
And thanks for watching us.
And please give
us your feedback,
what you're thinking about
this [INAUDIBLE] idea
for a next episode--
so an idea you have.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Totally.
Totally, yeah.
Let us know in the
comments below.
Let us know what
you're interested in
and what you liked the best.
That way, we could give
you what you want--
because that's why we're here.
NETO MARIN: Yes, exactly.
So thanks for watching.
See you next video.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Bye.